[موسيقى]
الهجره حلم يراود الملايين في العالم
العربي خمس السكان على الاقل في اربعه
عشره دوله عربيه يفكرون في الرحيل ايا
كانت الوسيله او الوجهه وفق ما افاد به
استطلاع للبارومتر العربي تحديدا في
الاردن السودان وتونس اين اعرب اكثر من
نصف السكان تقريبا عن رغبتهم في الهجره
والاكثر حرصا على هذه الهجره وملحاصلون
على شهادات جامعيه ومستويات تعليميه اعلى
ما يثير القلق من نزيف للعقول يهدد عمليات
التنميه في ظل معدلات اميه عاليه في
العالم العربي تصل في بعض التقديرات الى
اكثر من 27% وتشير دراسات عده الى ان
العالم العربي خسر جراء هجره الادمغه ثلث
طاقته البشريه ما يقارب الخمسين في المئه
من هؤلاء اطباء متخصصون وثلاثه تقريبا من
المهندسين والبقيه من مجالات مختلفه اما
الوجهه فكانت دول اوروبا وامريكا الشماليه
واسترليا كما تشير الدراسات ايضا الى ان
54% من الطلاب العرب الذين يسافرون للعلم
لا يعودون الى اوطانهم لندره فرص العمل في
قصتنا هجره العقول نرصد هذه الظاهره مع
ربيع بركات استاذ الاعلام اللبناني ومحمد
سيف الطبيبه التونسي ونجاح حسن خبير
البرمجيات العراقي نسالهم عن اسباب
السعيهم لترك اوطانهم كما نلتقي خبرات
عربيه سبقت الى طريق الهجره نبحث عن ابعاد
هذه الظاهره وتداعياتها مع خبراء كما
نتناول ما يراه البعض من جوانب ايجابيه
للهجره لاكتساب الخبرات العلميه
والتعليميه وسعي بعض من هاجروا لافاده
اوطانهم الام بقيه هذه القصه نستكملها مع
الدكتور نور الدين السالمي الخبير الدولي
والوزير التونسي والسابق والدكتور ايلي
ابو عون باحث اقدم في مجلس الادي والانف
روما المدير الاقليميه السابق في معهد
الولايات المتحده للسلام نسال ضيفين
الكريمين عن مدى خطوره ظاهره هجره الكفاءه
العربيه العاليه في ضوء الحديث عن قدره
المؤسسات التعليميه على تعويضها وعن حقيقه
الفرص التي يمكن ان توفرها هجره هذه
الكفاءات لمجتمعاتها الاصليه وعن السياسات
المطلوبه للحفاظ على هذه الكفاءات في
الوطن العربي لكن ما رايكم بدايه ان نشاهد
القصه وبعدها نبدا الحوار
خلال السنوات الاخيره هاجرت اعداد كبيره
من الكفاءات العربيه الى اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه بحثا عن افاق مهنيه واقتصاديه
افضل
اعداد يرجح ان تتصاعد خلال السنوات
القادمه حيث كشف تقرير البارومتر العربي
الصادر في يوليو 2022 ان الرغبه في الهجره
لدى ذوي المهارات العاليه في الدول
العربيه ازدادت وقد احتلت السودان الاردن
وتونس المراتب الثلاثه الاولى
كفاءات عده على امتداد الوطن العربي
اختارت الهجره بحثا عن افاق افضل
ربيع استاذ في الاعلام من لبنان يستعد
للاستقرار نهائيا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
نجاح خبير برمجيات من العراق يتهيا بدوره
للسفر بحثا عن فرص اخرى في الخارج
هيثم قصه نجاح لطبيب تونسي هاجر منذ سنوات
واستقر مثل العديد من زملائه العرب في
فرنسا
بينما يستعد سيف للسفر بدوره مثل مئات
الاطباء التونسيين والعرب الراغبين في
الهجره نحو اوروبا
[موسيقى]
قرر متاع الهجره ما هو سهل خصوصا ان في
الشعوب العربيه مرتبطين برشا بعائلاتنا
وليليان العلاقات الاسريه كبيره ساعات
نشوفه انه الهجره حاجه باش تدخل فيها
العلاقات الاسريه مناخل العمل اللي موجود
في البلدان هذه هو مناخ عمل مستقر
بالمقارنه
الهجره اللي نخم فيها هي اجره على الامد
القصير والامد المتوسط مش هجره نهائيه
ربما لكن هجره تخليك تكتسب حاجات جديده
[موسيقى]
بلبنان من مسار الانحداري اللي شفناه
ابتداء من
انتفاضه تشرين 2019 والانهيار يلي اشعل
يمكن هاي الانتفاضه بالتاكيد بدات مليان
محط تظهر قبل هلا صعوبات
ما كانت ظاهره بنفس القدر بالسابق بالتالي
في كميه من الاحباطات اللي ممكن اي ساكن
بهاي البقعه الجغرافيه من العالم انه يشعر
فيها اكيد هيدا بده يشجع البعض على الاقل
لمحاوله تامين الخلاص الفردي
[موسيقى]
موضوع هو ليس بهين لان انت هتغير مكان
حياتك او مكان تواجدك او مكان وعيشتك من
مجتمع الى مجتمع اخر وما تعرف يعني انه
هذا المجتمع هل راح تتاقلم وياه ام لا فشي
اكيد الهجره اللي صارت خلال هذه الفتره
وايد صارت يعني الدول الاجنبيه بسبب
المشاكل اللي قاعد يصير بالبلدان هذي
تقنية نحن
احتمال ما نلقاه بغير دول فشي اكيد نطلب
ننتقل الى احد هذه البلدان احتمال النجاح
يكون بها موفق
[موسيقى]
انا هجرت لي فرنسا في البدايه بسببه وكان
استكمال تربصات فرنسا سنه غابة من
التربسات الاقامه في الجراحه العامه وكان
حلم اي طبيب شاب هو الاستكمال التربسات في
في اوروبا وفرنسا كانت الوجهه البديهه
يعني للتونسيه
يظهر التقرير العالمي لرصد التعليم في
الدول العربيه لعام 2019 الصادر عن منظمه
اليونسكو ان اعلى معدلات الهجره لذوي
المهارات العاليه الى الخارج توجد في
لبنان والمغرب حيث يهاجر واحد عن كل اربعه
اشخاص من ذوي الكفاءات العاليه هذا وقد
حذر البنك الدولي في تقرير صدر عام 2020
تحت عنوان الكساد المتعمد من ان لبنان
يواجه استنزافا خطيرا في موارده بما في
ذلك راس المال البشري حيث تزايدت هجره
الكفاءات كخيار يائس
[موسيقى]
من جمله العوامل او الظروف غير المساعده
اللي بتدفع عاملين بالقطاع التعليمي
للتفكير بالهجره او للهجره حياتها تقديم
ابحاث علميه عم بتضيف
للانتاج المعرفي كل واحد يمكن بمجاله او
باختصاصاته من جمله هذه العوامل ما يتعلق
بضعف البنيه التحتيه بالبلد مثل الانترنت
بالحد الادنى من السرعه مثل كمان قدره على
التنقل من مكان لاخر
مناخ يتعلق مثلا بالحريات يلي هي يعني
محدوديتها حاضره وجاثمه بالعالم العربي
ولكن متفاوته بين بلد واخرين يمكن بلبنان
شوي في مساحه هذا الشيء بشكل خاص بالعلوم
الانسانيه له قيمه كبيره لانه بيسمح لك
انك هيك تبحر من دون ما تكون معتبر انه في
سقف للمدى اللي انت ممكن توصل له بحثك
العلمي وهذا شيء بيزعل واحد ما بيقدر يلوم
حدا خصوصا اذا ما كان عنده خيارات او
عندها خيارات ثانيه
الظروف اللي مر بيها البلد كانت ظروف صعبه
انا متاكد ومتيقن هسه اي دوله تقدمه او اي
بلد متقدم اذا تصير بيه ظروف من الظروف
العراقي يصير بنفس اللي صار عندنا بالعراق
هم هجره وسفر وهروب من البلد اغلب
الكفاءات واغلب الناس المتخصصه في مجال في
كثير من المجال الاعمال الموجوده
ادى الى زياده في عمليه الهجره
انا بصراحه احب مجال عملي واحب المكان
اللي اشتغل بيه الانسان تقريبا فتره طويله
احب اطور
الكفاءه مالتي وارجع اخدم بيها بلدي
[موسيقى]
فرحانين بالوضع اللي موجود في الاقسمه
تاعنا في السبيطارات متاعنا في عنا ساعات
تقف لعمليه مع في برشا بلايس اخذت مثلا ما
يخدمش فمش مكيفات مثلا طبيب شيب في حصه
استمرار يخمم في المريض
في التحاليل عنده التحاليل الكل موجودين
في السويدار ولا ما عندوش تحاليل الكل
يخمم في الماتريل
موجود الكل ولا مش موجود الكل فتلقى روحك
ساعات تحاول تلقى في حلول اخرى باش تجيب
هالحكايه هذه
الخارج
نخدم عشرين ثلاثين في المئه نخدم به نخدم
فيه
[موسيقى]
من كل مشاكل الدول الناميه في نهايه الامر
ما تقدرش تشتغل
وتقدم الخدمه الصحيه اللازمه للمريض في
ظروف سيئه اي طبيب شاب يخرج من تونس
ويسافر لفرنسا طبيعي
الفرق الفرق شاسعه
جمله من العوامل فسر بها الخبراء تعاظم
ظاهره هجره الكفاءات منها ما يتعلق بعوامل
داخليه مرتبطه ببلدان المغادره واخرى
خارجيه متعلقه ببلدان الاستقبال
من مفارقات ان هذا يحدث في الدول التي
اعطت قيمه للتعليم هذا المفارقه الكبيره
بدرجات تونس المغرب لبنان والاردن هذوم
البلدان اللي على مستوى العربي في مستوى
التمدرس وفي التشجيع على الدراسه او في
انتاج مخب على جميع المستويات تعتبر من
البلدان العربيه المتفوقه عن مستوى عربي
هذه المفارقه هي البلدان الان التي تكتوي
بلده بنيران هجره ابنائها
الدول الكبيره عم تصفير جدا من هالاسمات
اللي عم تحصل وهو عم نحكي نحن بمنطقه
العربيه قلت اكثر من 100 الف من اصحاب
العقول واصحاب الشهادات العليا من اثنين
دول عربيه هن لبنان وسوريا والعراق
والاردن ومصر وتونس والجزائر والمغرب هاي
الدول اكثر شيء عماله تتعرض
لخساره مواردها يعني عم يقدموا عوامل
لاصحاب العقول واصحاب الشهادات العاليه
حتى يوصفوهن لانه هن بالمقابل بالمقابل
هذه هذا التوظيف عندي يساعدهم
عام 2022
التحق ما يزيد عن الف ومئه طبيب تونسي
بمئات الاطباء التونسيين والعرب الذين
سبقوهم الى فرنسا بعد اجتيازهم اختبارات
القبول في مستشفياتها
[موسيقى]
هيثم احدها هؤلاء الاطباء الذين اختاروا
الاستقرار في مدينه رانا الفرنسيه ليصبح
من الكفاءات البارزه في جراحه وزراعه
الكبد طبعا المسافه
في البدايه لم تكن سهله يعني السنوات
الاولى كانت صعيبه ولكن
كانت عندي رغبه كبيره في تخصص في امور
دقيقه وخاصه الاختصاص الجراحه الكبد وزرع
الكبد الاختزاز هذين للاسف ما هوش متقدم
في تونس
التكوين فيه صعيب ولذلك قررت منذ سنوات
الاولى البقاء في في فرنسا
هناك طلب في الضفه الاخرى للمتوسط في
اوروبا عموما التي تبحث عن مثلها هؤلاء
الشباب الاذكياء المثابرين والمتكونين
جيدا للمشاركه في تنميتها
كفاءات علميه عاليه التكوين تفقدها
بلدانها الاصليه بينما تعد مكسبا لبلدان
الاستقبال التي احسنت وفادتها وتوظيفها
على مستوى المنطقه العربي في خسائر سنويه
حوالي 200 مليار دولار يعني في كل سنه
حوالي 100 الف من اصحاب الشهادات اطباء
مهندسين من اصحاب المهارات اختصاصين
بتشكل خسائر كبيره عن المنطقه ليش لانه
الدول العربيه ومنها لبنان بيكلفوا كثير
عليهم لاعدادهم وتدريبهم وحتى يخلصوا مثلا
الطبيب او المهندس حتى يخلص دراسته
الجامعيه كل الناس او اغلبيتهم عدم يفكرون
في الهجره
كل تصميمهم كل
مؤهلاتهم وكل شيء يعملوه يعملوه من اجل
الهجره وبالتالي سينقص تركيزهم في بلدهم
مثله مثل عديد الكفاءات العربيه الاخرى
المدفوعه بغياب رؤيه تشدها لاوطانها
استقر ربيع في امريكا بعد اشهر قليله من
مقابله له قادما من لبنان
علاء تي في بلدي انا حريص انه ما تنتهي
وما قادر اطلع منها ولا رغبين اطلع منها
بتمنى ان يكون قادر اكون جزء من شبكه من
اللبنانيين العاملين بالخارج بقطاعات
مختلفه
القادرين ربما على تقديم شيء ما لخدمه
بلدهم مجتمعهم حتى ما يكون كل عمل انتاجي
بالخارج عم يروح صدى من دون ما يكون
مستثمر حقيقه لخدمه
بلدنا يلي اضطرينا انه نظهر منه
[موسيقى]
الامكانيات في المستشفيات نحن نقول ممكن
العام الفارط الف هاجروا لو الامكانيات
تتحسن في المستشفيات اغلبيه الالف اللي
هجروا بشقائهم رجعوا لتونس وتتحسن الوضعيه
السياسيه والمناخ السياسي والمناخ
الاقتصادي في البلاد
ممكن يكون عنا اكسي كثره ولا طفره كبيره
في الاطباء
لن تستطيع الدول العربيه القضاء عليها على
الاقل على المجال القصير يلزمنا نركز على
الايجابيات لازم نحاولوا ننقلوا الخبره
اذا ما نحاولوا نستفيدوا بالخبرات
الموجوده في اوروبا وفي كندا وفي امريكا
الوطن دائما
والحلم بالعوده دائما موجود حبل الود وحبل
التواصل مع زملائي واصدقائي في تونس
ما تقطعش مشيت لتونس للقيام بعمليات ربما
تقريبا 15 20 مره للمساعده
توازيا مع حاجه الدول العربيه لبلوره
مقاربه للحد من هجره الكفاءات يؤكد
الخبراء والمختصون ان التحكم في الظاهره
يمر حتما عبر صياغه استراتيجيات سياسيه
اجتماعيه واقتصاديه متكامله
الهجره العائلي كتير كتير لها دور يعني
مثلا فينا نقول هلا الخليج مثلا الامارات
قطر الكويت وغيرها عم يشجعوا كتير كتير
عوده الاطباء عوده المهندسين
الاستفاده من التقدم والتطور العلمي
الموجود في الخارج ونقل هذه البرامج وهذا
التطور الى البلدان مثل لبنان او سوريا او
غيرها
قد تختلف الاسباب التي تدفع اعدادا كبيره
من الكفاءات العربيه الى الهجره
لكن النتائج واحده وان تفوتت الانعكاسات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه من بلد الى اخر
ما يطرح الاسئله ان كانت الحكومات العربيه
قد قطعت فعلا خطوات عمليه في اتجاه تثمين
هذه الكفاءات والتشجيعها على البقاء او
عبر اعاده استقطاب ذوي المهارات العاليه
الذين هاجروا وتحفيزهم على العوده
والاسهام في تطوير مقدرات بلدانهم
التنمويه
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام كما نرحب
بضيفينا الكريمين هنا في الاستوديو دكتور
نور الدين السالميه الخبير الدولي والوزير
التونسي والسابق ونرحب من تونس بالدكتور
ايلي ابو عون الباحث اقدم في مجلس الاديان
والامن في روما المدير الاقليميه السابق
في معهد الولايات المتحده للسلام اهلا
بضيفين الكريمين نبدا معك الدكتور نور
الدين انت من تونس ضيفنا من لبنان وهو
موجود في تونس يعني الحركه يعني ما شاء
الله ابلغ دليل ربما هو تجربتكما انتما
كلاهما الدكتور نور الدين اود بالفعل ان
اقف عند تجربتك وهي تستحق فعلا الوقوف
عندها شابا هاجرت الى فرنسا درست هناك
عملت هناك
لعده سنوات عشر سنوات تقريبا ثم عدت الى
تونس وعملت في تونس حتى تقلدت منصب وزير
وبعدها عدت الى الهجره ماذا كان الدوافعك
في كل مره بين رحلتي الشتاء والصيف ان صح
التعبير بين الهجره والعوده الى الوطن
شكرا على الاستضافه
احيي طبعا كل المش وظائف في الكريم من
تونس
تجربتي حقيقه يعني
تكون تجربه يعني تشمل هذا وذاك لاني عشت
في الغربه وعشت في تونس ثم هجرت مره ثانيه
الاسباب متعدده كما هي الاسباب لعديد
المهاجرين واسباب العوده ايضا يعني هي
محاوله المساعده ومحاوله العوده الى البلد
الام ورد شيء من الجميل للبلد
في تونس الوضع بعد الثوره لاني انا عدت
بعد الثوره كان مختلفا وكان مشجعا كما هو
الحال بكثير من
المهاجرين الذين هاجروا في قبل الثوره
ورجعوا الى تونس الدواء في الاول هجرتي
كنت طبعا
هاجرت للدراسه في الخارج في فرنسا
وتحصلت على الدكتوراه واشتغلت تقريبا عشر
سنوات في فرنسا ثم عدت الى تونس الدواحف
الاول طبعا علميا للتحصيل العلمي
للدكتوراه وايضا اقتصاديه لتحسين الوضع
وكان ايضا فيه يعني مجموعه متشابكه من
الظروف
ومجموعه متشابكه ايضا من الدوافع منها
سياسيه منها اجتماعيه منها ايضا مساله
الحريات وما الى ذلك ثم بعد الثوره رجعت
على امل طبعا المشاركه في الشان العام
ويعني ارجاع شيء من الجميل للبلد وطبعا
للمشاركه في هذا الانتقال الديمقراطي الذي
حدث في تونس
دامت الفتره الى سنه 2020 يعني منذ زمن
ليس ببعيد وشاركت في تقريبا كل الحكومات
منذ الثوره الى سنه 2020 وتقلت فيها
العديد من المناصب من بين طبعا
الاول عديد الوزارات من بينها وزاره
التربيه والتعليم العالي والبحث العلمي
ايضا ثم انهيت مسيرتي في تونس بمنصب وزير
الان يعني اجد نفسي نوعا ما مضطر لهذه
الهجره من جديد
لسبب واضح وهو نوعا ما انتكاسه
الانتقال الديمقراطي والتجربه الديمقراطيه
في تونس الدكتور بالفعل نور الدين ربما
سمعناه في فيلمنا الليله ونسمعها ايضا من
لقاءات عديده مع شباب عربي كون مجتمعاتنا
العربيه تعتبر بيئات طارده من عده نواحي
سواء سياسيه او اجتماعيه او اقتصاديه او
ايا كان ذلك اعود اليك طبعا دكتور نور
الدين لكن دعني اتحول دكتورنا الكريم من
تونس دكتور ايلي انت لبناني وهجرت الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والبنك الدولي في الواقع اعطى توصيفا اود
ان اتوقف عنده معك فيما يخص هجره
اللبنانيين تحديدا سماه بالخيار البائس
لماذا باعتقادك وانت شاب لبناني هاجرت
ايضا من لبنان
اول شيء مساء الخير
ومساء الخير لدكتور نور الدين صديق العزيز
انا اللي بحب اقوله بهالمجال انه
لبنان مثله مثل الكثير من الدول في
المنطقه كانوا دائما هن دول مصدره
للمهارات والادمه
وظاهره الهجره ليست بجديده يعني خاصه
لبنان بشكل خاص نحن بنعرف انه في جاليات
لبنانيه هاجرت من 150 160 او 120 سنه الى
بلدان مختلفه ولكن كمان اوافق على توصيف
البنك الدولي بانه هذه الهجره هي خيار
بائس لانه طريقه الهجره واسباب ودوافع
الهجره اختلفت يعني من 50 او 70 سنه كانت
دوافع الهجره هي اقتصاديه بحته اعود اليك
دكتور نور الدين سمعت عباره يعني تعتبر
جميله ظاهرا ما سماه تعتبر لبنان اعتبر
[موسيقى]
يعني ثوره
من الدول العربيه
ويستثمر فيها كثيرا ولكن مع الاسف تسلم
على طبق من فضه او تسلم على طبق من ذهب
لهذه الدول الغربيه بدون مقابل مع الاسف
وهذا خساره واضحه للدول العربيه
يعني ايضا في الموضوع نوع من المبالغه
يعني دول غربيه ايضا تهاجر كفاءاتها يعني
نتحدث عن مثلا بريطانيا عن المانيا ايضا
تهاجر بعض الكفاءات روسيا ايضا تحدثت في
وقت من الاوقات بان تهاج الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه الكفاءات هل الموضوع يختلف
بالنسبه لنا هل هذه الدول بامكانها فعلا
ان تصدر ونحن في امس الحاجه بالنظر لنسب
الاميه العاليه ايضا في مجتمعاتنا ولعل
هنا المفارقه ايضا في الموضوع نعم
المفارقه انه هذه الدول الغربيه يعني
المانيا او روسيا او غيرها هذه الدول ايضا
مصنعه وهي دول الدول العربيه هي تخسر خيره
ابنائها لانها لا تستطيع ان المشكل لا
تستطيع ان توظف يعني هذه الكفاءات وهي في
حاجه الى الكفاءات في كثير من يدافع على
هذا الطرح ويقول يعني فيه جوانب ايجابيه
للهجره من بينها تخفيض البطاله والعائدات
التي يدفعها او يرسلها يعني المهاجرون الى
دول الهم او ايضا فيه تبادل بين الدول او
هؤلاء الخبراء او هذه الكفاءات في الدول
الغربيه فيها تبادل مع الدول الام او
البلدان الام ولكن في خساره اقتصاديه
كبيره وفيه يعني اشكال الدول العربيه انه
الوضع في الدول العربيه هو وضع طارد لهذه
الكفاءات الدول الغربيه هي مستضيفه وهي
جاذبه لهذه لهذه الكفاءه
دكتور نور الدين هناك من يرى بان هذا
المجتمعات الغربيه هي مجتمعات تشيخ ونحن
لدينا فائض من الشباب فائض في الكفاءات
فائض في اين الضير في ذلك ان صح التعبير
ما هو الاشكال هو انه هذا الفائض بين
ظفرين من الكفاءات هو الدول العربيه هي في
حاجه اليه يعني هي هي هو ليس يعني كفاءات
عاطيه عن العمل او غير قادره ان تعمل او
تشتغل في الدول العربيه هي فيه تقصير من
الاداره وفي تقصير من اقتصادات هذه الدول
لانه هذه الكفاءات هي يعني كفاءات يمكن ان
تستعملها الدول العربيه ويمكن ان يعني
تستفيد منها ولكن هي تعارضه وتتوجه يعني
الى الغربيه وفيه اشكال ثاني هو انه هذه
الدول الغربيه هي دول لها استراتيجيه لها
سياسه يعني ممنهجه ومدروسه لاستجلاب هذه
الكفاءات العربيه
من تونس من لبنان من الجزائر حيث استنزفت
ربما كف اءات صرفت عليها هذه الدول الكثير
من الجهد والمال والوقت واستقبلتها فرنسا
سنعود الدكتور قال لي كنت تتحدث تحديدا عن
لبنان لبنان في اخر استطلاعات الراي يبدو
ان اكثر من 61% من الحاصلين على تعليم
جامعي يرغبون في الهجره وكنت تتحدث عن هذه
النقطه اود ان اسمع منك قبل ان ينقطع طبعا
نعم شكرا اللي كنت عم اقوله انه دوافع هذه
الوجه تغيرت الهجره تاريخيا كانت دائما
موجوده ولكن انا بعرف كتير مهاجرين ذهبوا
في الخمسينات والستينات الى بلدان مثل
افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وعادوا الى
لبنان
بثروات او يعني مبالغ ماليه سمحت لهم
بالاستقرار في لبنان اما الان الذي يحصل
ان دوافع الهجره من بلدان مثل العراق
ولبنان وسوريا وغيرهم وتونس هي ليست فقط
اسباب اقتصاديه هي اسباب تتعلق جانب منها
بالوضع الاقتصادي وجانب اخر يتعلق بغياب
الافاق الحراك الاجتماعي يعني اليوم الشاب
او الشاب التونسيه او اللبنانيه
يتخرجون من الجامعه لو توفر لهم فرصه عمل
ولكن لا يمكن لهم ان يروا كيف يمكن ان
يتحركوا بالسلم الاجتماعي ولا يمكن لهم ان
يروا او يستطلعوا كيف سوف تتحسن نوعيه
الحياه عندهم وما هي
[موسيقى]
في هذا الخصوص الاستفاده من هذه الكفاءات
التي لديها الرغبه في ان تفيد
نعم لا انا انا يعني انا اثق بانه لدى
الكثير من المهاجرات والمهاجرين هذه
الرغبه ولكن عندما يحين يعني لحظه القرار
بالعوده من العوده هناك عوائق وعوامل اخرى
تمنع هؤلاء الناس من تحقيق هذه يعني هذه
الرغبه وبالتالي يعني انا بعرف كثير من
المهاجرين العرب كان بدهم يرجعوا ولكن
شايفين انه بلدهم لا في استقرار لا في فرص
عمل ولا في امكانيه الاستمرار بالتقدم في
نوعيه الحياه مثل ما ذكرت والحراك
الاجتماعي وبالتالي خاصه يلي بروح بصير
عنده عيله مثلا يعني شخص هاجر الى كندا
لنفترض واسس عائله واطفاله عم يدرسوا
بالمدارس والجامعات الكنديه ما راح يرجع
ما راح يتركهم كل هذه الفرص ويرجع على
لبنان او على تونس فقط لانه حابب يرد
الجميل وبالتالي
العاطفه الجانب العاطفي موجود والرغبه
موجوده ولكن هناك عوائق امام تنفيذ هذه
الرغبه وهذا يجعل
ليستثنيه للمره الثانيه حتى وان كانت مثل
ما قلت النيه موجوده للاسف الدكتور نور
الدين يعني
اسدنا ظاهره هجره الاطباء التونسيين راينا
هيثم راينا ايضا الشاب الموجود ايضا في
تونس الذي يرغب في الهجره هو ايضا طبيب
وكما تحدثنا من قلب من قبل كان هناك نزيف
للاطباء شاهدنا ذلك قبل ازمه الكورونا
خلالها وبعد ازمه الكورونا الدول عديده
تستفيد من هذه الكفاءات في الواقع كيف ترى
انت انواع الهجره من بلداننا العربيه الى
هذه البلدان الاوروبيه
بالفعل هي بعد الكورونا يعني استفحل الامر
لانه فيه طلب لانه هو سوق في نهايه المطاف
سوق لهذه العماله او لهذه الكفاءات في
العالم يعني السوق فيه طلب متزايد بعد
كورونا في الدول المستقطبه وفيه عوامل
طارده اكثر مع الاسف في الدول العربيه
وخاصه الوضع السياسي والوضع الامني
وانتكاسه يعني الانتقال الديمقراطي والوضع
الاقتصادي ايضا الذي هو بطبيعه الحال
معلوم من البدايه
فالاسباب حديده ومتعدده يعني بالضبط اسباب
اقتصاديه ولكن ايضا فيه اسباب سياسيه
والوضع الامني والصراعات والحروب وما الى
ذلك ولكن ايضا فيه اسباب اجتماعيه لانه
كما ذكر الدكتور ايلي يعني
المهاجر يجد متسع يجد يعني حياه كريمه يجد
حياه اجتماعيه يجد حريه يجد العديد من
الجوانب ثم ايضا في عوامل نفسيه وعوامل
ذاتيه ليش لانه هذا المهاجر عندما يهاجر
يعني يكون له امكانيه الحصول على الجنسيه
او الاستقرار وما الى ذلك وبالتالي
المجال مج العوده صعب جدا وفيه هذه يعني
هذه العصا والجزره يعني الدول العربيه
تشهر العصا في وجه يعني الكفاءات والخبرات
والدول المستقطبه يعني تمدلها الجزره هذا
الاشكال فقط الجزر يعني الاغراءات كبيره
جدا من الجانب الاخر اعود اليك دكتور
اللافت في الواقع ان اغلبيه الراغبين في
الهجره من كفاءات العربيه اولا شباب لكن
ايضا من بلدان عربيه تولي التعليم اهميه
كبرى يعني وتضعه في قائمه اولوياتها نتحدث
عن تونس المغرب لبنان الاردن دول عديده
عربيه في الواقع كيف تفسر لنا ذلك
يعني انا
الموضوع انه
هذه البلدان التي ذكرتيها حضرتك هي خير
دليل انه الموضوع غير مرتبط فقط بوجود
نزاع مسلح وغير مرتبط فقط بوجود ازمه
اقتصاديه وبالتالي في مجموعه عوامل هي
التي تدفع هؤلاء العالم الى الهجره وكمان
يجب الاقرار انه عنا مشكله بالنظام
التعليمي بالمنطقه يعني نحن نتكلم عن نظام
تعليمي باغلب 90% من الحالات من شان ما
نظلم الجميع هو نظام تعليمي صار قديم وغير
ملائم مع تطورات اللي حصلت في الغرب وغير
هؤلاء المتعلمين في هذا النظام التعليمي
القديم يعني وهنا المفارقه ان نفهم
نعم نعم مع سوق العمل المحليه في فجوه
كبيره يعني اذا بتشوفي مثلا عدد الاطباء
يلي عم يطلع في فائض كبير وفي جوانب اخرى
فيها يعني عم يطلع اختصاصات عم يطلع فيها
ناس اقل من المطلوب لانه نظام التعليمي
صار خاص يعني متجه الى الربح الخالص
وبالتالي هو غير مكترث
بحاجات سوق العمل الحقيقيه الدكتور نور
الدين يعني ما المتغيرات باعتقادك الحاكمه
لتفضيل البعض الهجره الى مكان دون اخر دول
الخليج ايضا اصبحت يعني جاذبه ايضا لهذه
العقول العربيه راينا ذلك يعني منذ امد
طويل لكن في الفتره الاخيره زاد هذه
الهجره صح لنا تسميتها كذلك تماما هو
خليني يعني اعرج على لا اتفق تماما مع
الدكتور ايليفيا مساله انه هذه الخبرات
ليست بالكفاءه اللازمه لانه فقط يقع فيه
انتقاء والتصيد لهذه الكفاءات العربيه
واغلبها عندما تهاجر تكون يعني جاهزه تكون
جاهزه عندها الكفاءات والمهارات وما الى
ذلك لانه يؤخذ صفوه الصفوه واحسن ما انجبت
هذه البلدان حتى انه يكون عملي ومنتج من
البدايه فانه طبعا العموم قد يكون يؤخذ
فيه ويرد ويؤخذ عليه ويرد في التعليم في
الدول العربيه ولكن هذه الكفاءات هي من
خيره ما وجد ولهذا يعني
يقع فيها اقتناص وتصيد لهذه الخبرات
بالنسبه للدول يعني تاريخيا الهجره كانت
الى الدول الغربيه اوروبا وامريكا
الامريكا الشماليه واستراليا ولكن ايضا
فيه الان هجره الى الدول دول الخليج
بالخصوص كثير من الخبرات العربيه
والمهارات والكفاءات العربيه تاتي الى
الدول الخليج ولكن ايضا في مجال فيه تفاوت
يعني رغم المشهودات التي تقوم بها العديد
من الدول
في تمويل البحث العلمي وفي الاستثمار في
الكفاءات وما الى ذلك ولكن ايضا فيه مازال
فيه في الدول الغربيه كثير من الاغراءات
وكثير من الجوانب يعني مما ذكرت منذ قليل
يعني مساله الحريات مساله
الجنسيه وكثير من المسائل الاخرى التي
ترجح كافه الدول الغربيه رغم انه فيه طبعا
توجه الى الدول في دول الخليج الان نود ان
نقف حقيقه على هذا الاستنزاف لهذه
الكفاءات ان صح التعبير من منظورك كيف
تراه يؤثر على البيئه الاصليه التي هاجر
منها هؤلاء اي نوع من التحديات يفرضها
اقتناص كما سميته زبده الزبده او هذه
الكفاءات التي كان يمكن ان تحدث يعني
فارقا في بلدانها الاصليه هو مع الاسف
يعني هذه الكفاءات تغادر ويبقى لها اثر
قليل بعد مغادرتها يعني رغم انه فيه
امكانيه تواصل مع هذه وفيه امكانيات طبعا
مساعده وفيه امكانيات ادلائي بدلوها في
كثير من الجوانب ولكن مغادرتها بما انها
هي الصفوه بما انها هي النخبه يعني يفرض
حاله من الفراغ من المواقع التي يعني
غادرتها فانه سواء كانت في الاداره او في
المؤسسات او في الجامعات او مختبرات البحث
هذه الكفاءات تترك فراغ كبير وهذا طبعا في
كثير من الدراسات تثبت وتؤكد يعني انعكاس
هذا على النمو وعلى الجانب الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي وحتى جانب السياسي والحريات
وحتى المثقفين يعني فيه جانب كبير
ربما تفتك منهم هذه الانظمه التي يسببون
لها وجع في الراس تقول يعني ليذهبوا يكون
ذلك ربما افضل هذا افضل الانظمه طبعا لبعض
الانظمه اكيد دفنت له الدكتور ايلي اعود
اليك مره اخرى يعني كيف ترى انت من منظورك
تداعيه استمرار هجره الكفاءات نتحدث عن
اطباء نتحدث عن مهندسين
ما تاثير ذلك على المدى البعيد ايضا على
اقتصاديات هذه الدول من منظورك
التاثير كبير جدا اولا التاثير له مفعول
يعني تقريبا قصير المدى وهو
غياب الخدمات يعني في بلدان بلشت نوعيه
الخدمات
تتاثر بها خدمات طبيه خدمات تعليميه الى
اخره بسبب هذه الهجره
والانعكاس على المدى المتوسط والبعيد هو
انعكاس اقتصادي كبير يعني يمكن دكتور نور
الدين بيتكلم فيه اكثر هذا لانه عنده خبره
اكبر بالموضوع ولكن يعني كل اقتصاد
المنطقه كله راح يتاثر لانه عم بصير
المجتمعات الموجوده في المنطقه هي مجتمعات
يعني
شو بقولوا عجوزه او يعني عم يغلب عليها
الناس اللي عمرهم كبيره
وبالتالي نحن يلي عم بصير عنا هي نفس
المشكله التي تعاني منها بعض الدول
الغربيه واللي هي كانت حافز لهذه الدول
الغربيه لتشجيع الهجره اليها
نحن هلا عم بصير فينا نفس الشيء بالمنطقه
وبالتالي تاثيرها بالمدى القصير مثل ما
قلت هو توفر الخدمات ونوعيه الخدمات يعني
اليوم افضل الاطباء مثل ما انذكر بتونس في
لبنان في العراق كلهم هاجروا وبالتالي انا
معمول انه الاطباء البقيؤوا مش كفوئين
ولكن عدد اطباء الاطباء الكافرين طبعا اقل
من العاده نفس الشيء ينطبق على مهن اخرى
او قطاعات مهنيه اخرى وعلى المدى الاطول
هو يتعلق بقدره هذه المنطقه على النمو
الاقتصادي لانه الحركه الاقتصاديه كلها
سوف تتاثر مع الوقت وسوف يعني يمنع هذا
يمنع المنطقه من من
اعتقادك ما سبيل ربما للحد من هذا النزيف
طبعا الاصل هو ان يترك الناس احرارا
يختارون يعني ان صح التعبير طريقهم يشقون
طريقهم في الحياه يعني ذلك مشروع ان يريد
الانسان ان يحسن من حياته لكن ماذا عن هذه
الحكومات ما الذي يفترض ان تقوم به مثلا
هل من تنظيمات تشريعات مثلا تجبر ربما
الطلبه الذين يدرسون في الخارج على العوده
للعمل بعدد سنوات معينه الاطباء ايضا ربما
عليهم بعد التخرج ان يعملوا لعدد سنوات
معينه ام ماذا ما تصورك لنوع الحل
لا انا انا لا اعتقد انه اجراءات فيها
اكراه هي تنجح في اعاده الناس بالعكس يجب
ان نخلق بيئه تجذب هذه الاشخاص من دون
اكراه وهذا ممكن اول شيء علينا الاقرار
انه المنطقه لا تستوعب كل الاشخاص اللي عم
يتخرجوا منها وبالتالي في جزء من
المهاجرين لا بد من ان يبقى مطرح ما هو لا
يمكن للمنطقه ان تستوعب كلها هؤلاء
المهاجرين ان يعودوا اليهم ففي جزء منه
بده يبقى الجزء الثاني اللي ممكن نرجع
نستعيده او نستفيد من خبراته يجب خلق بيئه
جاذبه لالهم تبدا مش فقط بالعامل
الاقتصادي ولكن تبدا ايضا بالجانب
الاجتماعي الجانب السياسي يعني يجب ان
نبحث عن استراتيجيات وطنيه فيها عده جوانب
وانا انا شخصيا لا اعتقد انه سياسه واحده
تتعلق فقط بجانب من هذه الجوانب هي مفيده
يجب ان يكون هناك استراتيجيه شامله فيها
جانب اقتصادي جانب اجتماعي جانب سي
ولكن خليني اكون عملي في اعطيك التجربه في
تونس في تونس بعد الثوره مباشره ان كان
فيه يعني شبه رؤيه او تصور لاستعاده هذه
الكفاءات وذهبنا في خطوات عمليه وقمنا
بخطوات عمليه اولها في وزاره التعليم
العالي والبحث العلمي قمنا بجرد واحصينا
قرابه 4500 يعني كفاءه عليا تونسيه موجوده
في الخارج ولم
نتفاجا باراده هذه الكفاءات التواصل مع
الدوله والادلاء بدلوها والتعاون يعني مع
السلطات ومع الدوله ومع المجتمع التونسي
ولكن مع الاسف يعني
اصطدمت هذه المبادره
بالبيروقراطيه ويعني الوضع في في الاداره
التونسيه هذا جانب الجانب الثاني حتى نكون
عمليين يعني لانه القضاء على هذه الظاهره
يعني مش ممكن لن لا يمكن يعني منع الناس
من الهجره ولا يمكن فرض العوده على
المهاجرين وبالتالي خلينا نكون عملين وحتى
لا يكون طبعا المساله مساله فقط مساله
شعارات
اعتقد يعني راينا في بدايه الثورات يعني
صفر هجره غير شرعيه يعني كان ذلك يعني نوع
من الامل غرس في نفوس الشباب ووقفه توقفنا
جميعا يعني مبهورين امام هذا الشباب
الواعي الذي ليس الجانب الاقتصادي في
نهايه الامر هو الذي يدفعه دائما للخروج
مجرد بارقه امل بان الامور ستتحسن بان
هناك اراده اندفعت الشباب يعني حتى من
قليلين الكفاءات نتحدث عن من ياخذ قوارب
مطاطيه للهرب من بلده تماما هذا هو
الاشكال ولكن الموضوع هنا موضوع الهجره
هجره الكفاءات فانه بعد الثوره اضف على
ذلك انه فيه عوده من المهاجرين الكفاءات
الكفاءات المهاجره الى بلدانها حتى انها
تدلي بدالها يعني
شكليه او او ما الى ذلك مثلا
وزارات التعليم العالي والبحث العلمي كما
قامت الحكومات في تونس في قبل بعد الثوره
مباشره في البدايه يعني نقوم بمرصد او
نقوم
بقائمه فيها جرد لكل وهذا موجود يعني كل
الدول لها قائمه في
الكفاءات المهاجره سواء خرجت للدراسه
وبالتالي القائمه موجوده في وزاره التعليم
العالي والبحث العلمي او الاطباء او
المهندسين او ما الى ذلك الخطوه الثانيه
هي التواصل مع هذه الكفاءات يعني لنكون
عمليين كل الوزاره كل الحكومات لها سفرات
ولها قنصريات
علاوه على الملحق الثقافي والملحق
الاقتصادي ومش عارف الامني والعسكري ومش
عارف ايش كل هذه يمكن ان يكون في كل
قنصليه يعني شخص يتواصل
او يتواصل يعني مع وزاره التعليم العالي
ووزاره ويمكن ان يقوم بعمل كبير جدا عمليا
على الميدان يتواصل ويقوم بالتشبيك ويقوم
بربط وايضا تسهيل الامور لهذه الكفاءات
هذا هذا جانب اول ثم جانب الثاني الدول
يجب ان تعطي مزيد من الاعتمادات للبحث
العلمي نحن نعلم الاحصائيات تقول انه
الدول العربيه في هي في ادنى سلم الدول في
دعمها لتمويل البحث العلمي سؤال اخر
للدكتور ايلي اود ان اسمع منك دكتور ايلي
وانت مهاجر تصورك لامكانيه الاسهام الذي
يمكنه يمكن ان يقدمه المهاجرون لبلدانهم
الاصليه
[موسيقى]
الخبير الدولي والوزير التونسيه السابق
كما اشكر من تونس ضيفي الدكتور ايلي ابو
عون باحث اقدم في مجلس الاديان والامن في
روما المدير التنفيذي او الاقليمي عفوا
السابق في معهد الولايات المتحده للسلام
خدم حلقتنا من برنامج القصه بقي نعود ان
القاكم باذن الله الاسبوع القادم مع بقيه
بقصه جديده السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]